since the start of this bruising
campaign conservative challenger yoon
sekyo had remained neck and neck with
his liberal rival lee jae-myong
exit polls put them within a percentage
point of each other and so began a
sleepless night for many in south korea
following local broadcasters animated
depiction of this epic struggle until
yoon emerged as winner just
i am deeply grateful to all of you and
the people who have supported a beginner
to this point
a political newcomer he first came to
prominence as a lead prosecutor in the
imprisonment of disgraced former
president park geun-hye following her
impeachment for corruption five years
ago yoon comes into this job having held
no political office but presenting
himself as a force of change politically
and socially conservative he is in stark
contrast to five years of liberal rule
he's also promised a much tougher line
with north korea but many question how
much of that is campaign rhetoric
i think president yun seo gil is going
to choose very pragmatic foreign and
national security policy at least for a
while it comes after an increase in
missile testing by the north with the
threat of launching longer-range
missiles of the kind that have brought
the korean peninsula to the brink of
conflict in the past rob mcbride al
jazeera seoul